couple theories as to why Tucker Carlson
was removed from Fox News this story
just from the other day on
post-millennial AOC demands Biden admin
regulate Tucker Carlson Fox News due to
incitement of violence uh I just like to
point something out um
how do you regulate incitement to
violence does anybody have a suggestion
you'd be in jail yes incitement of
violence is a federal felony and how do
we regulate for people who are
committing felonies we arrest them and
put them in jail AOC said on MSNBC to
jensaki that what Tucker Carlson is
doing is incitement to his incitement to
violence in the government should be
involved they should be regulating this
or whatever she's what they're doing is
the typical leftist weasel words where
she's of course implying that Tucker
Carlson should be arrested and charged
but then saying no of course I I mean
they they should stop hate speech or
something and it's like you accused took
a cross out of committing a felony
incitement to violence that is I'm
pretty sure defamation per se meaning
it's so egregious to accuse someone of
committing a crime that it's much much
easier to overcome the burdens in time
view Sullivan Tucker Crossing is
probably just Sue AOC outright for
saying this I hope he does because there
are people who really incite violence
like Savannah
that's right yeah you know what no I I
really I really hope that he does though
because to be quite honest I am tired of
these leftist politicians who do
continue to incite people to violence we
can look at the lgbtq community antifa
black lives matter the list goes on and
on we can look at you know at the FBI
and all the times they've entrapped
Americans and tried to incite them to
violence let's go ahead and get into all
of that and we want we have AOC over
here talking to the Biden Administration
demanding them to take Tucker off of
there it's absolutely ridiculous you
know Chuck Schumer yeah that's what I'm
saying Chuck Schumer came forward too
because he was saying that uh you know
Tucker Carlson uh killed democracy it
was the destruction of democracy when he
came out and he showed the American
public more January 6th footage that the
j6 commission was withholding it's just
absolutely ridiculous to me and I'm so
tired of being run by criminals but
that's just where we're at in America in
2023 uh you know the left can go ahead
and incite violence against us all day
long but um Tucker Carlson can't go and
accurately report on his own show
elected oh sorry I was just saying AOC
doesn't see that this is an endorsement
of Tucker like
that this is their guy right because
there are people and you know it is a
little bit of partisanship anything else
C says is wrong and to be fair that's
not an entirely bad judgment but now
that she's saying he's like Vines they
know he's not they know that she as a
representation of the left establishment
is afraid of him it makes him even more
powerful especially to those who support
him well exactly you should say he's
such a threat that he needs to be
imprisoned he needs to be taken off the
air yeah and of course like you said
they accuse every single person who
disagrees with them of inciting violence
that's the new version of calling
somebody racist all it means is you have
said something that I disagree with the
term ends up losing all meaning etc etc
the other uh Theory as to why I Tucker
Carlson is removed so I got the idea
here is that AOC is saying he's
committing a crime there's been big
pressure you know so Ma I doubt that's
the reason but you know maybe but the
other big question is Tucker just moved
to Florida
it was reported by the New York Post the
New York Post deleted the article
because I guess I had revealing
information as to where he lived why
would he go down to Florida well
Florida's nice it's a good retirement
but he did so in the past week which to
some insinuates that he knew he was
about to leave Fox News so this could be
kind of like a retirement jenkuger of
the Young Turk said he believes that
Tucker Carlson was trying to get fired
on purpose because he intends to run for
president
several others are implying that he may
be Trump's vice presidential pick which
would be the smartest move that that
would would have been the smartest move
at any point ever except for the fact
that no one believed it possible because
Tucker was working at Fox News now that
Tucker Carlson is a free agent
Trump Carlson 2024 sounds extremely
plausible I would like that even better
if he had kept his residency in Maine
and then we could have Maine's very
first anyone in the Oval Office you know
they'd have never had a president
they've never had a vice president I
think Maine deserves that win and Tucker
Carlson would have been the best pick
for it is that your main concern
um
it wasn't just a pun it wasn't just upon
it was a legitimate question do you
spend a lot of time thinking about
someone coming from me because I'll just
say is someone from Illinois someone
from Cook County I'm hoping whoever's
elected is not from there any election
New England really needs to hold on
otherwise they're gonna have to merge
into one state to have any kind of
electoral power but in being serious I
think when people pick vice presidents
they do want to show that they are
representing a different part of the
country that's why we picked Pence
initially right we have this Brash New
Yorker and then we have this like
Evangelical uh standard republican from
the Midwest in some ways obviously we
know Tucker Carlson is not like he does
spend a lot of time in Maine but he's
not really from there it would represent
different parts of the company although
it would be East Coast dominance I think
it's
I think it would be an extremely
unorthodox move to pick a VP who's from
the same state that you are claiming
residency in although I will say I have
not been interested in following the
2024 like pre-election stuff so far I
feel like Trump's kind of bored me I'm
not gonna lie like the constant
bickering with the santis but Tucker
being involved like obviously it's not
confirmed that he's going to be VP but
him just being involved in you know the
speculation that this could now be a
thing has made 2024 a lot more exciting
a lot more exciting I would say yeah I
mean I I would love to see a trump
Carlson ticket yeah that'd be great yeah
yeah I mean a trump Carlson ticket could
be a very interesting thing I would I
mean how would that work Tucker is just
gonna Lobby DeSantis to be his VP picker
Tucker would run a campaign in the
primaries
oh I'm sorry not DeSantis my bad Trump
or you like talk to Trump and say like
oh make me Donald The Establishment
wants you to think I can't be your VP
pick I can't actually or does does
Tucker launch his own presidential
campaign
yeah yeah Trump that's what I think Tim
Scott's trying to do I think that's why
he's like I have an exploratory
committee I'm thinking about running for
president being like Trump please notice
me I'd love to be VP then Trump me to
them and says don't run and we'll give
you a position or something like that we
will give you that's probably a lot of
what what it is for for all these people
who are running they just want Trump to
appoint them somewhere yeah yeah I could
see that but Tucker Carlson will be
legit yeah I think that makes a lot of
sense the thing is uh apparently before
Tucker moved to Florida he had met with
with Trump and I think Marjory Taylor
green or something like that so the
speculation was that something's been in
the works for a minute
I wouldn't be surprised I feel like his
relationship with fox has been uh
strained for long enough you know not
everything as much as we uh appreciate
what he does there's it doesn't Gonna
Last Forever it wasn't sustainable long
term and I don't think either one of the
parties were entirely happy happy with
uh the dynamic between the two of them
no I mean look Fox is going to try to
find their new like bad boy too their
new anti-establishment guy and it's
going to be super crazy well exactly
because they're going to want to to be
someone with sort of the veneer of being
trans aggressive but who will never say
the kinds of things Tucker Carlson the
fact that we
[Laughter]
we've got more news as to as to why
people think Tucker may have been ousted
to check us out Jonathan uh kogan says
BlackRock increased position in Fox
Corporation fintel reports that
BlackRock has filed a 13 G5 a form with
the SEC disclosing ownership of 45.74
million shares of fox corporation which
is they say it's an increase of 14.75
percent an increase in total ownership
of 2.7 percent do you think this play
day role in Carlson's departure
I don't know I mean probably isn't
BlackRock like a principal ESG company
interesting I mean it certainly could be
a factor certainly could be a factor I
don't think they're in love with Tucker
Carlson and what he's saying and doing I
don't think any one in court he's the
only one on TV the only Corporation the
only Corporation he was earning money
for didn't even like him so
yeah has Tucker criticized BlackRock
before
I wouldn't be surprised yeah he has to
have but I mean that's the thing
blackrock's the one company he's like
four years I like them four years Tucker
Carlson has had multiple segments
talking about BlackRock
yeah well see and the amount of things
that he's talked about from again
January 6 the FBI the doj all of the
corruption and that from the economy to
the Border it's like he was talking
about real substantial issues uh not the
distractions that the mainstream is
continuously pushing our way so it was
only a matter of time before he was
eventually taken off air because I mean
we we've all seen how powerful Tucker
segments were we've all seen you know
how much sway he had in the public uh
how much support he does have so yeah I
mean I wasn't even surprised when I saw
this to be quite honest
yeah it was only a matter of time right
he wasn't going to spend the rest of his
career there but I mean how old is he
he's in late 40s no he's older than that
I think he's the 50s
yeah 53 years old I mean 53. oh wow I
love that that's the picture that comes
up when you Google them it's the exact
picture you think would come up it's
that it's the face the the face where
he's scrunching his face
he's 53 he's not quite at retirement yet
but he is at be the VP age I guess it's
what retirement ain't about your age
it's about your bank account he's got a
big one you're gonna absolutely step out
if you wanted to there's I don't think
he wants to though but there's other
questions about whether or not he just
saw how much money was being made by
people who were independent and he
realized that Fox News was just taking
everything from him you know I could see
it I mean I'm gonna be like Tim Poole No
One's Gonna be taking my cash for me as
much money is he making that's too much
how much money is Tim making no one
should have that much the government
needs to take that he makes that much to
voice Dr fauci on freedom Tunes it's
ridiculous and I wonder how much uh Fox
News was trying to censor and suppress
what he was trying to discuss I wonder
how much that was going on behind the
scenes as well so yeah that is why again
you know the Independent Media is
um so enticing to so many people because
then you're not Tethered to anybody or
anything you have nobody lording over
you telling me what you can and cannot
say and you know people have been making
the meme all day Tucker Carlson
Unleashed which I think is uh spot on
but what if he didn't even want to talk
about politics this whole time and
that's how Fox got he wants to be like a
minister he's like actually if I if I
use my diamond ax and keep hitting this
I don't know that he really wants to
like get off the ground he's like here's
my video I say on why SpongeBob got bad
after the first 10 years he's playing
OverWatch I just think that Hearthstone
you know part of it isn't even about
retiring it's that the landscape I think
people are
it's so rude for interrupting me I think
that the landscape of American media and
politics has changed so dramatically
that you know no one who goes into media
right now knows exactly where their
career will be in 10 years and I think
that's always been true of talker
Carlson it would be surprising to me if
he hadn't seen some sort of writing on
the walls and been plotting an exit the
weirdest thing about this to me is that
it's so abrupt I I don't yeah I don't
know if it was it was apparently like he
got 10 minutes notice yeah thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time